>>IT'S TIME NOW FOR FRIDAY
FOLLIES.
IS THIS ONE OF THE STEIN  --
SIGNS OF THE APOCALYPSE?
HERE TO EXPLAIN IT TO US AND SO
MUCH MORE IN TONIGHT'S FRIDAY
FOLLIES IS NEW YORK TIMES
BEST-SELLING AUTHOR RAYMOND
ARROYO.
LET'S HOPE THAT'S NOT A FATHER'S
DAY TREND.
WHAT'S UP, RAYMOND?
>> I'VE GOT TO START WITH THIS
BIBLE MANIA.
EARLIER THIS WEEK, THE SOUTHERN
BAPTIST CONVENTION AND THE
CATHOLIC BISHOPS CHASTISED THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION FOR THEIR
IMMIGRATION POLICY.
SAYING, ST. PAUL TELLS US YOU
HAVE TO OBEY THE LAW.
LOOK.
>> WE ACTUALLY DID DIG THROUGH
THE BIBLE TO FIND PASSAGES THAT
LENT THEMSELVES TO THE CURRENT
BORDER PRACTICE OF SEPARATING
MIGRANT CHILDREN FROM THEIR
PARENTS.
I WANT TO BEGIN WITH MATTHEW 14.
BUT JESUS SAID, SUFFER LITTLE
CHILDREN AND FORBID THEM NOT TO
COME UNTO ME.
>> WHO IS FORBIDDING CHILDREN
TO COME TO JESUS?
THIS IS CONFLATING THE SCRIPTURE
AND TURNING IT INTO A PUBLIC
POLICY THAT IT WAS NEVER INTEND
TO BE.
>> HOW LONG DID THE BIBLE
READING GO ON?
>> NO, NO, NO.
THIS WENT ON AND ON.
HE LOOKED LIKE A THEOLOGIAN,
LOOK.
>> I'M NOT FINISHED THIS.
LET'S GO TO ISAIAH 10.
WOE UNTO THEM THAT DECREE
UNRIGHTEOUS DECREES.
>>THAT ONE'S INTERESTING.
BUT THAT'S AN OLD TESTAMENT
READING.
IS HE SUGGESTING WE SHOULD
FOLLOW GOD'S COMMANDS AND THE
KINGS FOLLOW HIS ORDERS?
I DON'T THINK SO.
LOOK, THIS POLICY SEPARATING
PARENTS HAS BEEN ON THE BOOKS
FOR YEARS.
THEY DID IT DURING THE OBAMA AND
BUSH ADMINISTRATION.
NOW THEY'RE SAYING GOD WOULDN'T
WANT THERE
WANT THER
WANT  HER
WANT  THR
WANT  THIS
WANT  THIS.
THERE ARE A LOT OF THINGS GOD
WOULDN'T WANT.
>> ALL THE CATHOLIC CHURCHES --
>>WE HAVE TO GET INTO THE
EXPLOSION OF MEN WHO ARE DOING
PLASTIC SURGERY, OKAY?
>> I KNEW YOU WOULD WANT GO
HERE.
I HAVEN'T HAD ANY.
>> I LOVE THIS SEGMENT.
WHAT ARE THE MOST POPULAR TYPES
OF PLASTIC SURGERY FOR THE
METROSEXUAL MEN OUT THERE WITH
THEIR SKINNY JEANS, MAN BUNS,
AND MAN PURSES?
>> THE FIRST IS KNOWS
RESHAPING, THEN EYELID SURGERY,
LIPOSUCTION, BREAST REDUCTION
WAS NUMBER FOUR.
>> WHAT?
BREAST REDUCTION?
>> HAIR TRANSPLANTS WERE AT THE
BOTTOM.
I THOUGHT THAT WOULD BE AT THE
TOP.
BREAST REDUCTIONS TOP IT.
I DON'T NEED HELP THERE JUST
YET.
>> WHEN PEOPLE SAY THE WORD
MOOB, IS THAT WHAT THEY'RE
TALKING ABOUT?
OKAY.
SO MEN JUST WANT --
>>I HOPE NOT.
>> IT'S NOT AN AUGMENTATION.
IT'S A REDUCTION.
>> THEY ARE REDUCING THE MAN
BOOBAGE.
KRAFT CHEESE.
CAN YOU IMAGINING DOING A
PROMOTION LIKE THIS FOR MOTHER'S
DAY, SAYING MOM IS CHEESY?
I DOUBT IT.
I HATE THIS DIMINISHMENT OF DAD.
I SAW PLANET FITNESS PUT OUT A
CALENDAR OF DAD BODS.
IT'S FATHER'S DAY.
WE SHOULD CELEBRATE MEN AND
FATHERS.
>> CELEBRATE FATHERS, MALE ROLE
MODELS ALL ACROSS THE COUNTRY
WHO ACT AS FATHERS.